man has a huge following not just on
Twitter and on social media but for his
comedy tours that lit up places like
Madison Square Garden and so on and so
forth and now for the first time since
2013 his fans can see him again in the
tell it like at his tour that just
departed his lovely favorite Boston
Massachusetts locale Dane Cook here on
the Rich Eisen yeah look I like that you
mention Madison Square Garden because
people usually don't put like Dexter's
pizza shop in 2000 the world's most
famous arena is they like to say is that
one of the greatest I mean be backstage
there and having walked by Madison
Square Garden on the way down to the
village to do shows at 2:00 3:00 in the
morning for many many years that was a
real treat to say the least yeah yeah
you are to let me describe to the radio
audience wearing your Boston Red Sox
t-shirt right here's the only show you
can do where they actually accept logos
we are we are definitely local agnostic
here on the show it does look old-school
is there any history to this or you just
bought like an old-school shirt this was
one of the last shirts I got with my dad
my dad was an all-around athlete 1952
the Boston Braves were scouting my dad
and so I have pictures I don't know if
we have any but I have pictures of me
and like Red Sox jewelry jewelry when I
was like three years old rings and
necklaces and so this was the last shirt
my pop got me an okay I got to be cool
to wear today and we just saw in the
commercial break you taken a video of
you and your dad watching the final out
of the o for world series occur speaking
being broken yeah and so who was your
guy who was your red sock growing up who
was it oh man just everybody I was such
a I was such a I was like born and
raised in Fenway I mean I literally was
doing like homework there cuz my dad
knew all the guys and so I'd go there
after and you know junior high school my
dad would swing me down to a well first
we stopped at the DAV and my dad would
have a couple of pops and then we head
into
way so it was just being entrenched in
and loving that feeling of rooting for
these underdogs at the time to break
this curse right you know so I love ya
and I loved you know just all the
throwback guys you know my favorites
Fisk oh yes I'm Fisk it you know my
favorite one is of it's Fisk like he
there's a picture of Fisk correct me if
I'm wrong Brock can you get another
fellow red sock I over there of him
thrown out a ceremonial first pitch
flipping the bird at the side of his at
the side there's something like that
like an old school you know and I always
because I get to work with Deion Sanders
yeah I just on occasion I'll bring up
Carlton's name cuz you know he and Deon
got into it cuz Deon would draw a dollar
sign in the in the batter's box but it's
that when he stepped in as a rookie yeah
and Fisk was having none of them yeah oh
that's great was with the White Sox
and the two of them really got into it
oh yeah you know it is pretty cool so I
throw out the first pitch twice at
Fenway now that's got to be the most for
somebody who's sold out Madison Square
Garden where obviously you you you are a
confident individual to do what you do
for a living right my jokes didn't go
like that pitch they would be calling
gotta be the most nerve-wracking thing
you've done right yeah especially with
my dad there in him being this athlete I
used to say like I I played football for
one play in high school and I would tell
the story that I got hit so hard it
knocked me right into West Side Story
song-and-dance man within like ten
minutes after that so there's my dad the
athlete and I dirtball it the first time
out and he said what he said so many
times he goes you sucked in a Little
League in you suck now he meant didn't
that Boston loving like trust me was not
a hazing you got hit so hard used to
because you're you're like I think I'm
playing oh yeah
I think I play in the NFL then all of a
sudden you're singing Maria yeah in a
bedazzled vest in hand you're a shark
yet you gots funny too man Dane Cook
here on the Rich Eisen show so you must
be in cloud were you here for the in Los
Angeles yeah latest clincher yes yeah
it's I was in Colorado on that latest
clincher for the Red Sox I still can't
get over okay one day you guys are get
back there
keep climbing that lighter so says the
Yankees fan over there
Oh II said we got more we got more
that's like I've gotten more laughs over
20 years nothing matters except the last
laugh that you get the ones you've got
ten years ago those are in the closet
you could say okay there's not much
killing it the last 15 years understand
it's an excellent analogy but but when
it all does come down to it you want to
talk about the history of the game sure
no you can talk about both but yeah I'm
trying to I'm trying to talk my way and
so okay I've got some claims to fame
here that I need to check with you okay
it's not a technically our celebrity
true or false bolo I do want to play
Stark bench cut a game that we play here
on the Rich Eisen I'll try shortly
within a second true or false that you
have intercepted Tom Brady at one I did
a charity event for Best Buddies back in
Boston says charity yeah but he has his
game he plays quarterback for both teams
very last play of the game my team's
down I see Tom he's gotta throw this
cute kid who's you know been excited to
get a ball thrown to him all day so I
see Tom's elbow line up I go this kids
not getting this ball so I ran over and
I jumped this kid pulled it down rend it
in for the game-winning touchdown and he
signed the ball I got it in my living
room
are you proud I just take six understand
but you made a kid cry that boy just
this this young child like 12 you
stepped in front
that was my that's the only way I was
ever gonna intercept upbringing you know
I played in a flag football game or it
called actually a flag football game for
Madden back in the day and I saw Joe
Montana was playing the game and it was
warming up before and I'm like all right
Joe I gotta I gotta step in here I got a
cat
pass he goes okay if you think you can
catch it I'm like oh geez what the hell
do I just get myself into I'm just
thinking to myself all right I just need
to catch it I just need to catch it as
I'm running I'm like in my head I might
get like the little engine that gotta
catch it I got again and as soon as I
turn the ball hit me right in the chest
I had no choice but just to grab it
right because he was anticipating the
throw
oh man so I'm wondering what's tougher
to not catch a pass that you're not
anticipating or to read Tom Brady's eyes
cut off a 12 year old and take it to the
house day so here's another one is it
true that you were in the room when Tom
Brady met Giselle that is true
that was true is this 207 AFC playoff
game in San Diego
Pat's Chargers and San Diego Chargers at
the time and Giselle was sitting with us
in the box so the Kraft family was like
our Giselle's here - she'd never seen
Tom play and she's really no football
she literally during the game was like
so why do they have to run with the ball
this way understand why both teams don't
help each other she was had that very
thing and then we all were ushered down
to the locker room and when I saw them
see each other and she kind of grabbed
him by the arms and they're looking at
they're almost the same height but she's
looking at him because you know he's
bigger in their life and they were so it
was well it was like they were so
beautiful you know those moments in like
a Disney movie where the camera just
spins around the prince and princess I
thought I was just spinning around and
the birds start flying it was
unbelievable you were like oh that's a
power cut I think I called my girlfriend
right there most like we're done where
we have nothing even close to what I'm
experiencing him so let me again so
you're there as with the Patriots in the
owners box right right right yeah and
Giselle just happened to be invited
separately yeah and then then you all go
downstairs and you walk right the the
romance suspension essentially happened
I watched this happen you know when they
you know googoo gah-gah eyes like this
is
what they had they had all the things
that are a fiction that you were like oh
okay I just I just have to stand it I
felt like voyeuristic just standing
there watching them love each other live
in the locker room in the locker room
what made you want to go back on tour
again do you know accepting of this is
my 29th year doing stand-up and I've
done a lot of tours over the years and
the only thing that I can guarantee 100%
as a comedian that we all want even
though we have very different approaches
is you don't to go out there until you
know it's locked and loaded and ready to
go and that it's gonna deliver and this
last three years I really stayed in LA
and I didn't stop doing stand-up I just
worked on taking my routine to what I
think I'm 47 now in a couple of weeks
I'm in the act two of my life and career
and I wanted the comedy to reflect that
without losing what we call the LP m's
which is the laughs per minute mm-hmm so
it took me a little bit longer to
cultivate it and now we're back out on
the road
deliverance so you started is age 18
yeah 1990 where Boston where I grew up
in Arlington Massachusetts okay
ten minutes north of Boston and and just
started doing stand-up open mic nights
in and around the Boston area my first
set ever I went to a catch rising star
yes and I was watching open mic and they
would just pick random names from people
that signed up previously that's how
they got you to come back you may not
perform the next week but if you signed
up you might get picked and I was
sitting in the fifth row and the host of
the show looked at his list and he goes
okay up next randomly here where's
earnest Glen mm-hmm I look around wait
for you know earnest Glen's hand go up
earnest didn't show up my hand goes up
mmm I point to me goes your earnest Glen
yeah yes I am
he was my intro all the way from the
fifth row earnest Glen so my first set
ever Thank You Ernest Glen by the way I
never found this guy I looked on
Facebook I thank you earnest Glen you
gave me a career not be in there it's
like it's like when you're in a raffle
and the first tickets pulled and it's
nobody and you just want to say it's my
ticket but then you actually have to
have the receipt you didn't have to have
the receipt to be honest Glen I just had
to have the
I don't know if I can say it but the
cojones to be listen not everyone has
the con is to be understand no no no
they don't notice so you killed it and
then you've been Dane Cook ever since
yes after that I went back to my my
original stage 8 yeah that is some
impressive stuff
ok so let's play start bench cut with
Dane Cook I've got a handful of trios
for you you have to start one bench one
cut one it's like that you know you know
marry and you know what and kill quiet
alright play the music we're start with
Dane Cook first one out for you Dane
Cook start bench caught bases-loaded two
outs bottom of the ninth who do you want
at the plate in their prime Mookie Betts
David Ortiz Manny Ramirez start bench
cut Ortiz you didn't stutter start
you're gonna start start Ortiz bench
who's the last one Manny and it's mookie
betts I'm gonna I'm gonna go Manny next
yes and then Mookie's on the bench you
do realize that it's not against the
Yankee's and that's David or so so Ortiz
you've cut your cutting you're benching
Mookie and you're cutting Manny that's
right I'm on Orthodox rich okay say the
least
Big Papi everybody the greatest clutch
hitter of all time
David Ortiz correct not on the Minnesota
Twins David Ortiz this is in there prom
in their prime I'm just bitter okay
alright second one for Dane Cook third
and five Tom Brady's under center who do
you want the ball to go to in their
prime Julian Edelman Rob Gronkowski Wes
Welker start bench cut I'm gonna go
Edelman and then I'm gonna go Welker and
then you're cutting drunk I'm gonna cut
Gronk I need I need an explanation
yeah no there's a right or wrong here
Richard this is just not its preference
but I you know I mean I heard sighs I
never thought I'd hear a sigh with all
due respect to the great Wes Welker he
did drop a pass on the sukkah
by the way great fantasy football name
that's a great one
okay very good you know let's move on
Game seven of the World Series Dane Cook
who'd he sent out to the mound
Pedro Kurt Schilling Roger Clemens start
bench cut gotta go showing is gonna
start I'm gonna bench Clemens and then
Pedro and Manny Ramirez at least I
understand with Manny room at least I
understand Manny Ramirez Schilling huh
he's you're easier guy yes donut that
was an unbelievable you know just what a
step-up moment with I know the sock and
yeah you mean the red sharpie that
dredge RB as I was at it oh yeah you
don't think so every single day it's not
been natural I'm sorry it's not the
natural Roy Hobbs yeah he had surgery on
his scars where the ketchup packets come
on all right let me get Mythbusters on
the phone last one for dead cook start
bench cut which one of these guys would
make the best stand-up comic Brady
Belichick or current Celtics head coach
Brad Stevens bench cut Dane Cook I'm
gonna start Belichick okay you gotta
you're here what would that sound like
it's it's it's very dry it's like Jeff
Ross level dry and then I'm gonna go
Brady and I don't remember who is the
red Stevens yeah yeah we're asking her
so I'll check open my Brady's gonna
follow me and Brad Stevens is the
earnest Glen Cincinnati yeah fine I mean
he'll you wouldn't want it you'd want to
be on but you want to open for Bill
right you want to follow bill yeah I'm
gonna hoping I'm the setup guy for Bill
Oh American exit is gonna be released
and available everywhere Tuesday May
14th what's this about that you are in
this films it's uh it's definitely
different from
stand up it's a dramatic kind of an
action thriller I play the father to an
amazing young actor Levi Miller and it's
basically about a father through after a
series of very strange events kidnaps
his own son and it's this road trip
action thriller that it's my favorite
performance that I've ever no kidding
had the opportunity to participate in
yeah the night comes out on on May 14
demand I think everywhere on May 14 I
Tunes Amazon the whole bit yeah the
whole bit well that's fantastic man Dane
Cook calm or Ticketmaster for tickets
you're next up here in California
Riverside California the Fox Performing
Arts Center then the Masonic in San
Francisco yeah you go to my parents old
neck of the woods in Red Bank New Jersey
before Philly sensing Indianapolis and
more thanks for coming on back rich I
really appreciate thanks for finally
having me at it's my it's my pleasure to
have you here on the show and and you
know come back Yankees Red Sox when does
the first game or it's in London right
isn't there game in London this year
London this year yeah again they're
there is a series in London this year
okay there we go we could take it that's
enough that's definitely roadtrip thanks
for coming out in my kids by the way
loved you in planes as well oh thanks
for it oh my gosh thank you yeah that's
just a that's that's got to be a dream
come true
unbelievable stuff for kids right oh the
best the greatest is great so thanks for
coming on Dane Cook at Dane Cook both on
Twitter and Instagram be part of the
following the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience